[Musique]
c'est tout un symbole
sonia ribes remet les clés du muséum
d'histoire naturelle à ses employés
après plus de trente ans de service la
conservatrice de ce patrimoine
historique prend sa retraite
j'ai pris mes fonctions c'était le 4
juillet 1990 on inaugurait aussi une une
exposition sur buffon et le musée
n'était pas en très bon état et
moi je me suis donné comme mission de le
repositionner à la fois sur le plan
scientifique sur le plan culturel et sur
le plan pédagogique
je vois là moi je vais retenir ça c'est
à dire que j'ai rempli ma mission
une soirée marquée également par la
restitution de la résidence d'artistes
taxi d'airbus le photographe laurent de
gebhart a réalisé 22 portraits d'agents
du muséum en costumes d'époque du début
du 20e siècle
des photos où chacun d'entre eux posent
avec un animal ou un objet de la réserve
du muséum une véritable transformation
et mise en scène de ses agents dans mon
idée c'était bien clair que je voulais
travailler sur de la lumière style
rembrandt la lumière qu'on peut trouver
dans les peintures de rembrandt
en clair obscur donc je c'est un peu le
fil directeur de travailler la lumière
donc en clair obscur pour ces deux
occasions
le personnel du muséum avait repris les
costumes d'époque ils soirée d'un autre
temps pour se souvenir et faire vivre la
mémoire du muséum d'histoire naturelle
de la réunion
[Musique]